les buy contre l'eire sur bfm business
nicolas doze accueille les experts
bonjour et bienvenue l'actualité de ce
lundi dominée par la conférence des
nations unies sur le climat on va très
largement en parler en essayant
d'évoquer notamment les enjeux
économiques ce que ça signifie vraiment
pour les entreprises et j'ai la chance
d'avoir un un expert auteurs de cet acte
qui travaillent véritablement sur les
implications entre la transition
énergétique et la vie réelle des
entreprises
la dernière fois qu'ils étaient venus
dans ce studio je crois que c'était il
ya trois semaines ou un mois ils nous
avaient dit si on double le co2 la
température monte de 4 degrés en moyenne
rachat semble peu 4 degrés seulement il
constatait il nous rappelait que depuis
la dernière ère glaciaire il y a vingt
mille ans et aujourd'hui la température
moyenne de la terre avaient augmenté de
5,2 grille ce qui veut dire que si on
prenait 4 degrés en seulement 100 ans
c'était véritablement absolument
colossal et vous savez l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'est d'aboutir à une
augmentation de la température limiter à
2 degrés d'ici 2100
remarque j'encule jancovici bonjour
bonjour bien vous qui aviez dit ça je
les dis absolument value sinon cas n'est
même pas changé d'avis depuis
peut-être le président deux chiffres
exacts et vous êtes associé de carbone 4
vous avez publié dormez tranquilles
jusqu'en 2100 et autre malentendu sur le
climat et l'énergie publié chez odile
jacob
avec nous il le gendre bonjour bonjour à
tous on attend d'explorer accompagné
agence d'intelligence et de
communication stratégique et ludovic
subran bonjour chef économiste d'euler
hermes on va évoquer les relations avec
les entreprises et tout ce que ça peut
signifier juste un mot sur carbone 4
beezik c'est vous qui avez inventé le
socle de réflexion et la mise en place
d'un nouvel indice boursier c'est
effectivement engagé par euronext qui
est un indice qu'on va baptiser 2° quoi
la 10° qu'est ce que ça signifie qu'il
ya derrière
alors c'est une méthode qui a été mise
au point par carbone 4 s'appelle carbone
inpact analytics avec notamment le
soutien de dire aux vins qui est la
filiale investissement
on va dire socialement responsables pour
faire simple de natixis
donc un asset manager et c'est une
méthode qui essaye de comprendre quelle
est la contribution possible d'une
entreprise à la transition énergétique
en gros on met en balance les émissions
que cette entreprise occasionne parce
qu'elle doit produire donc qu'elle doit
produire elle a besoin de matières
premières elle a besoin de transporter
cette erreur ça ça fait des éditions et
les émissions qu'elle est capable
d'éviter chez les autres parce que
l'utilisation de ces produits est
capable dans un certain nombre
d'endroits d'éviter des émissions un
exemple idiot si vous vendez de la laine
de verre et que vous la vendez dans des
bâtiments qui existe déjà
bah vous allez un peu diminuer la
consommation énergétique des bâtiments
qui existe déjà et ça ça fait baisser
les émissions et on regarde comment l'un
et l'autre se compare et si vous avez la
chance d'être dans une activité où ce
que vous faites va diminuer chez les
autres plus que ce que vous occasionner
en direct alors vous êtes compatible
avec la transition pour dire les choses
de manière un peu simple évidemment il
ya tout un tas d'entreprises qui n'y
sont pas encore mes agents sont plus ou
moins loin donc ce qu'elles font les
plus ou moins bien et c est cette
méthode a servi de base méthodologique à
la création de l' indice d'euronext et
on en est évidemment très fier et très
heureux
donc c'est cet indice
si on est compatible on va se retrouver
dans l'ain disent exactement à ta valise
sur lequel les investisseurs pourront et
c'est heureux avec qui qui va trancher
pour savoir si on rentre je rentre pas
dans l'indicé un conseil scientifique
d'euronext et compétent qui valait
calculer lui-même les crédits carbone
pas du tout scientifique de rolex il
vous fait confiance donc non le conseil
scientifique euronext a dit que notre
méthode était la méthode pertinente pour
faire ce genre de choses
après sur les calculs pratique nous qui
allons les faire d'accord c'est vous qui
allez faire justement avec vous et je me
tourne en jambes il faut que messieurs
dans un instant gilles legendre ludovic
subran ce que vous êtes sensible à cette
polémique pour savoir si c'est l'homme
ou pas qui est responsable
vous savez cette histoire de dingue est
ce que c'est le nom y on va paralyser
mais dès le matin terminal que pas fait
beaucoup de philo nicolas non mais non
parce que c'est l'activité humaine ou
pas qui a provoqué une un accroissement
colossal des émissions de gaz à effet
talent ça semble crever les yeux et
c'est vraiment le débat qui oppose
aujourd'hui les demandes les deux mondes
entre les climato convaincu et les qui
va toucher bras levés lundi les malades
moi je n'ai pas l'impôt ne suis pas
expert de la question mais j'ai
l'impression que la question est oui
évidemment c'est l'activité humaine qui
a provoqué cette élévation de la
température et et laurie aie aie aie aie
fait monter de façon exponentielle
le risque climatique sous tous ses
aspects et alors j'allais dire
maintenant c'est c'est pas ça le sujet
c'est pas ça le sujet le vrai débat
c'est comment on arrive à maîtriser ce
risque et à revenir en arrière sur une
tendance qui a été d'une violence et
d'une rapidité comme le rappelait tout à
l'heure jean-marc exceptionnel c'est ça
le c'est ça le vrai sujet aujourd'hui
et la vérité c'est que ce qui est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui c'est une
révolution
absolument fascinante on va pendant
quinze jours se tournent les yeux pour
savoir si oui la coop 21 va être ou non
un succès ça va être un peu ça la
question est alors que l'on sait qu'il
leur localité et que l'on sait que les
intérêts du nord et du sud sont
difficilement mais chili oui mais pas le
seul sujet c'est pas c'est pas le seul
sujet et j'allais dire nous n'aurons
jamais les outils objectifs qui
permettront de dire oui c'est sur moi un
succès non c'est sûrement un échec
ça va être quelque chose dans une zone
absolument grise et c'est pas à l'autre
de l'intensité du gris qui va falloir
juger cette conférence pour moi
peut-être par angélisme par optimisme
c'est déjà un succès mais pas la
conférence en tant que tel mais le
mouvement et la révolution qu'elle
représente dont on va certainement
pouvoir dire ici même qu'elle est
notoirement insuffisantes et je connais
les thèses de jean marc et j'ai souscrit
en large terre mais qui a un mérite
inouïe c'est d'exister
et cette révolution elle se manifeste
dans le fait que aujourd'hui elle est le
seul sujet positif de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui si on
cherche le vrai sujet qui réunit la
majorité et l'écrasante presque
l'exhaustivité des pays et des économies
c'est celui là avec des points de vue
différents avec des divergences avec des
conflits d'intérêts majeurs mais il n'y
a pas d'autres sujets qu'ils fassent
concurrence à celui ci pour créer une
sorte de mouvement international de
mouvement mondial
deuxièmement c'est le suivant j'ai fait
le buzz que les eiffage est important
alpes il n'ya pas d'incitation
économique
je les envie pas 150 ch justement les
sujets la décision des filets
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont décidé depuis cinq
ans rien du tout un art met ses lancers
deuxièmement c'est le seul sujet qui
khaledi oblige à penser la gouvernance
du monde d'une manière différente et
notamment pas simplement en termes de
lois de décrets de règlement de traiter
mais avec l'introduction de logique
incitatives dont on va certainement dire
et je l'entends je viens de l'entendre
l'instant qu'elles sont déjà qu'elles
sont déjà insuffisantes
mais elle dit que c'est cette logique là
qu est en train de se mettre en place
on a vu que le système contraignant à
kyoto ne fonctionnait pas lire et là
vous des professionnels et moqueries
we'reunion ou pas contre état d ailleurs
pris le barebone où on est au début tu
quelque chose et troisièmement et bhl
allez dire c'est que c'est apparemment
secondaire mais pour moi c'est
fondamental
c'est le seul
j'ai qui est aujourd'hui capable de
mobiliser la jeunesse au niveau mondial
quand on parle de politique à la
jeunesse c'est sur les questions
d'environnement et de climat
quel vin sport ludovic réaction à part
le chômage je veux dire il n'y a pas
grand chose qui intéresse les jeunes et
surtout pas le climat ça c'est déjà une
première ce n'est pas vrai ban a passé à
bouffer je pense que tu peux être vos
climato sceptiques ou pas c'est pas ça
qui compte au final
et oui il ya des gens qui commencent à
se mobiliser je suis d'accord je
souffrais avec la plupart des choses que
j'ai dites gillain propose le problème
c'est c'est juste l'un le ce qu'on met
derrière moi ce qui m'inquiète
aujourd'hui c'est que le débat sur le
climat c'est très pascalien c'est à dire
que comme pascal on sait pas vraiment si
à dieu ou pas et donc du coup on va se
comporter bien mais au final on fait
plutôt par doute que par vraie foi et
donc les gens les entreprises les
ménages et c'est plus ou moins se
comporter de façon un petit peu
meilleure vis-à-vis de leurs émissions
carbone mais au final je suis désolé il
n'ya pas d'incitation
moi je regarde un petit peu les
investissements les dettes des
entreprises qui sont décarbonés les les
points de pipe qu'on peut attribuer à
une transition énergétique et ses jeux
désolé en 2010 il ya une espèce de deux
micro état de particulièrement positif
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup d'argent
public et donc il ya eu des incitations
et donc on a fait des choses dans climat
depuis dans les économies avancées
il ya eu un moindre investissement dans
tout ce qui est friendly quand on parle
de réduction de carbone parce que les
énergies carbonées est au plus bas
depuis pas mal de temps et donc
forcément il ya beaucoup moins
d'incitations pour faire cette
transition énergétique pour l'innovation
pour les incitations fiscales n'existe
quasiment pas et quand elles existent
elles sont extrêmement volatiles
pour moi ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui
c'est il ya des secteurs et qu'elle ça
marche
les bâtis le bâtiment vers tout ce qui
importe énormément d'innovation et
d'ouverture et d'innovation encore une
fois il faut de l'argent pour cette
innovation verte et malheureusement que
ce soit l'économie verte où l'innovation
r moi aujourd'hui je pense que l'argent
qu'on avait commencé à voir pour
faciliter cette transition énergétique a
disparu
il y en a un petit peu sur les marchés
c'est intéressant je pense que monsieur
jean paul ici parlent de cette
expérience là parce qu'on voit les
indices verts qui eux attirent de
l'argent mais pour des raisons
d'arbitrage tout bête c'est à dire que
c'est les choses contre cyclique
donc ça attire les investisseurs parce
qu'ils ont pas cette espèce de
corrélation sur le portefeuille qu'on a
sur les autres actifs en revanche dans
les bilans des entreprises
moi ce qui m'inquiète aujourd'hui c'est
que la marque verte si vous voulez ne
rapporta n'est pas profitable à part
dans des cas extrêmement sa part que
verte alors allez-y jean marc jancovici
par rapport à l'optimisme
totalement débridée non attendez je
récuse absolument stable là j'ai pris
les précautions dire qu'on est au début
de quelque chose mais que ce début de
quelque chose introduisait une véritable
rupture dans la façon dont l'économie
mondiale est en train de se penser je
suis d'accord avec les deux c'est à dire
que lundi on est en train d'assister à
quelque chose qui est à une modification
à la rapide on va dire et l'autre dit et
si je fais un bilan à date pour le
moment il s'est pas encore passé grand
chose je suis d'accord avec les deux et
moi aussi très compliqué d'accord avec
gilles legendre quand il dit 150 chefs
d'état qui viennent dire on va se serrer
les coudes pour s'occuper du problème en
soi c'est déjà un succès et je suis
d'accord avec le constat qui consiste à
dire aussi oui mais c'est pas toute
l'histoire et je suis d'accord avec les
deux cas si on regarde ce qui fait
bouger les acteurs économiques ce qui
fait bouger les acteurs économiques pour
le moment on leur a donné un indicateur
aux acteurs économiques qui s'appelle
leur compte ça qu'on leur a donné
donc tant qu'on n'est pas capable
d'avoir des règles du jeu qui font que
les comptes sont plus sympathiques à
tenir dans un monde où un des carbone
que dans un monde où rendez carbone pas
il est carbone page est aussi bête que
ça
le décarbonés ça veut dire tenir compte
d'une externalités dont on tenait pas
compte avant c'est à dire eh bien ça
veut dire que vous devez vous occuper
d'un problème qui avant n'en était pas
un donc vous allez devoir dépenser de
l'argent ou et cetera donc c'est
nécessairement un peu plus pénalisant
mais jean marc jancovici comment est-ce
qu'on va demander à des pays de bien
vouloir faire ce qu'on n'a pas fait nous
lors de nos grandes phases d'expansion
et largement profiter de la gifle est
arrivé en gros il faut
si je prends un parallèle comptable
s'obliger à partir de maintenant à tenir
nos comptes
exactement comme s'il devenait grand
rêver d'une provision pour risques pour
remise en état du climat ou quelque
chose qui y ressemble à ça et d'une
dotation aux amortissements pour
consommation de ressources non
renouvelables
ok d'accord il faut jamais or
aujourd'hui c'est pas dans les comptes
ce truc là dont vous profitez en tant
que passager clandestin d'un truc que la
nature a mis gratuitement à la
disposition qui s'appelle les
combustibles fossiles et d'un autre truc
que la nature a mis gratuitement à la
disposition que j'appelle un système
climatique soit dit en passant sans
système climatique on n'est pas très
bien
donc vous avez aujourd'hui une
incitation à faire entre guillemets ce
qui ne va pas tout simplement pour des
raisons strictement économique donc il
faut renverser la logique alors est-ce
que le renverser la logique est
compatible avec la croissance
perpétuelle c'est tout le sujet alors là
non je vais moi je pense que notre la
question avait déjà reversé c'est ça le
sujet c'est parce que sinon ça ça fait
depuis longtemps
donc vous allez changer les règles du
jeu entre les gagnants et perdants c'est
un truc que les perdre on n'aime pas
vous allez devoir inventer une nouvelle
manière de conter et la diffuser c'est
un truc qui est jeu se fait pas en 24
heures est par ailleurs vous avez des
politiques qui en démocratie sont
toujours en train de survendre site une
faune avec le risque majeur qu'il vous
dise ça y est le monde est sauvé parce
qu'on s'est réuni et puis le lendemain
et moi je suis dit c'est la déception et
puis nous là on est entre csp + + donc
le climat ça nous intéresse je suis
d'accord qu'il ya tout un tas de gens
qui s'en foutent complètement
et je les comprends parce que leur
premier souci c'est de savoir s'ils
conserveront le club demain matin et
réconcilier les deux ça demande des
plans économiques qui sont compatibles
avec le problème
sa demande a besoin de chausser
demandons l'unanimité non non non non
non on aura créé c'est très français
comme différent on adore briller au sein
de l'aude lui fait l'unanimité n'a on
adore le blanc oui fallait qu'il faut
consensus qui est un peu différent de
l'unanimité d'accord mais là où on sur
van la chose c'est que c'est pas l'onu
qui a les cartes en main pour ensuite
faire en sorte que les gens se bougent
parce que tant qu l'onu ça remonte pas
au conseil de sécurité et qu'on n'envoie
pas les chars et les avions chez les
gens qui respectent pas leurs émissions
c'est pas l'onu qui décide c'est pas
l'onu qui a la main sur la fiscalité
c'est pas l'onu qui a la main sur la
réglementation s'est pas l'onu qui a la
main sur les règles du commerce mondial
tout ça c'est ailleurs c'est pas l'onu
qui a la main sur la fondation yves
férès et si les normes comptables vrai
les normes comptables etc pas l'onu non
plus qui s'occupe du conseil de
stabilité financière
donc ce que peut faire or c'est là que
les choses se passent qui vont avoir
pour le coup un vrai impact on parlait
tout à l'heure d'euronext
dans un domaine très voisin il ya le
gouverneur de la banque d'angleterre qui
a fait un discours remarquable il ya un
mois que vous avez peut-être parlé sur
ce plateau et qui a dit le risque climat
doit devenir un risque majeur intégré
par les investisseurs
le jour où vous allez dans les stress
tests du monde financier
rigolez pas c'est normal et je vais des
gens qui vous disent à votre tristesse
là il a une sale gueule parce que vous
avez trop de trucs carbonées dans vos
investissements ça ça va faire bouger
les lignes de manière significative
c'est déjà sait déjà et ça c'est en
train de se passer c'est déjà le cas on
fait comme l énorme et reste heureux d
eric schultz remplacement on est passé
d'une phase concerne l'écologie contre
et notamment les pionniers de l'écologie
était sur des positions hyper politique
assez idéologique et d'aller dire à
grand niveau d'affectivité pour les
registres ce sont ces gens là où ils
existent ils sont respectables
c'est comme pour la lutte des femmes les
pionnières ont pris des sacrés risque
alors on peut lire i on peut les moquer
mais c'était quand même fondamental que
quelqu'un se lance après l'écologie
politique a été comme très légèrement
dévoyé mais aujourd'hui le fait nouveau
c'est que l'impact du jeu ne fait rien
ou je ne fais pas assez commence à être
mesurées et sue et donc redouté
il ya des secteurs entiers de l'économie
qui se rendent compte que évidemment ça
va être très compliqué de changer ça va
problème au moins deux coûteux ça oblige
des revirement majeur on entendu plein
d'exemples sur votre antenne depuis ce
matin qui était passionnant je pense
notamment la directrice générale d'emi
qui a raconté le tournant avec des
terres qu'ils étaient en train d'essayer
de père et probablement avec des
ambiguïtés des contradictions mais bien
sûr tout ça est vrai mais il ya des
secteurs entiers qui se rendent compte
que de toute façon le système n'est plus
tenable et on s'en fout de l'onu là
c'est les secteurs qui vont devoir ce
qui va faire payer depuis sonné le glas
des sujets que c'est pas ce qui se passe
et ron monumentale et changer quoi que
ce soit le cas de l'assurance vie parce
qu'il ya des mamans où il faut célébrer
sa renommée leur kop 21 permet de
célébrer ses 20 ans a regardé la caméra
temps défini l'assurance l'assurance
aujourd'hui n'est pas tenable dans le
système actuel ce avec les risques
climatiques
elle n'est pas capable donc elle est
obligée de
façon se réformer mais elle va en se
réformant elle va obliger ses clients à
se réformer
parce qu' elle n'est pas c'est pas une
entreprise de philanthropie l'assurance
donc il va falloir qu'elle continue de
gagner de l'argent et si les sinistres
augmentent de façon majeure elle devra
augmenter les primes et si elles
augmentent les primes les boîtes sont
obligés de se réforment on marque une
pause vous réagirez dans un instant jean
marc jancovici aux débutants cette
émission j'avais dans dans l'idée que
les nations-unies réunissait des états
pour essayer d'arracher un accord qui
permettrait de limiter la hausse de la
température à 2 degrés à l'horizon 2100
et de débloquer une enveloppe de
financement de 100 milliards d'euros par
an pour les pays du sud d'ici à 2020
afin de réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre vont pouvoir maintenir le
réchauffement donc maîtriser et j'ai
l'impression depuis sa ville que tout
est ailleurs quand tout est ailleurs bon
vous allez me doutais aussi mais vers la
fin de l'histoire est d'ailleurs
compliquée après on vient on verra si
effectivement mais on verra si oui
qu'est que c'est bien oui mais on va
voir après si c'est le le progrès qui a
provoqué le réchauffement donc si le
fait de vouloir lutter contre le
réchauffement
il ya une forme de décroissance qui va
falloir inscrits derrière le fait que
cette complexité soit assumée et révélée
est un des signes qui pèse pour plus qui
permet de pencher pour un certain
d'optimisme
commençons d'abord par être compliqué la
peau on pourra y croira bullshit